Fritz.
Es geht mir nicht darum, meine Kinder bis sie hier ausziehen, sag ich mal, dann zu kontrollieren, aber sie ranführen, in den Umgang damit beibringen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall und sicherlich mit sechs Jahren ist auf jeden Fall vernünftig so.
Ich hab gefragt, was hast du für Erfahrungen dabei gemacht? Also wie wird das sozusagen jetzt von deinem Sohn? Also was für ein Echo hat das, dass du das mit ihm gemeinsam machst? Was glaubst du, wie das bei ihm sozusagen wirkt?
Ja, er versteht das noch nicht, warum ich das darf und warum er das noch nicht darf. Genauso versteht er auch nicht, warum er abends um 20 Uhr bei mir kein Fernsehen gucken darf. Und dann muss ich ihm das halt erklären, warum das halt nicht geht.
Und wie erklärst du ihm das?
Na, für einen Sechsjährigen laufen abends im Fernsehen Filme, die er nicht versteht, wo er Angst bekommt.
Ja, aber erklärst du ihm das genauso?
Ja, genauso. Also ich versuche ihm, die Sachen genauso zu erklären, wie sie sind, aber dann halt kindgerecht in dem Alter. So dass er sich verstehen kann. Das eine ist die Sorgfaltspflicht. Ich muss aufpassen, dass mein Kind solange, bis es das nicht selbst einschätzen kann und mich das vernünftig verarbeiten kann, was da gegebenenfalls geht, solange muss ich mein Kind davor beschützen und soweit es geht ihn dabei betreuen. Aber das andere Aspekt ist ja die Bildungspflicht oder den Bildungsauffrag dahinter. Also mein Kind soweit zu bringen oder das Kind soweit zu bringen, dass es irgendwann das selbst auch einschätzen kann und irgendwann am besten auch selbst weiß, was man auf Facebook stellt und was nicht. Und dass das genau das Partiefoto so ein Ding ist. Und bei dem ersten ist ganz klar, das muss bei den Eltern liegen, weil das geht nun mal nicht anders. Die sitzen nun mal im Haushalt. Bei dem zweiten ist es so eine Frage. Also ich glaube nicht, dass man von den Eltern verlangen kann, dass sie den kompletten Weg der Bildungspflicht, was die Medienkompetenz angeht, da selbst machen, weil sie einfach das Zeug nicht dafür mitbringen. Und wir haben da ja so eine Einrichtung, die genau in diesem Fall irgendwie eintreten soll, dass diese Schule, die all das, was die Eltern vielleicht 20 Jahre danach nicht mehr wissen und vermischt werden können, dem Kind halt beibringen. Und hier sehe ich ein riesengroßes Dichizid, weil das Thema Medienkompetenz noch immer also nicht antwortweise behandelt wird. Von zu kurz kommen kann man glaube ich gar nicht leben. Und ich glaube, dass hier ein riesengroßer Teil dieses Defizits begraben liegt. Ja gut, aber da muss man ja auch mal gucken, wo man als erstes ansetzen kann, damit man weiterkommt. Als ich zur Schule ging hatten wir Lehrer, die haben es nicht geschafft, ein Kassettenrekord anzukriegen. Die sollen unseren Kindern jetzt die Medien erklären. Also ich meine, du kannst nicht immer alles auf die Politik abschieben. Das will auch gar keiner, weil die selber damit überhaupt nicht umgehen kann. Sondern du musst dann auch einfach, wenn du ein Kind kriegst, ich meine, da hört ja Spaß auf. Da fängt das wahre Leben an.
Du selber kannst für dich machen, was du willst.
Aber da fängt ja Verantwortung nun mal an. Und dann...
Also ich möchte an dieser Stelle zwei Dinge tun. Das eine ist, mal eine Lanze für die Lehrer berechnen. Ich kenne ja persönlich einen Lehrer, der hat seine Diplomarbeit darüber geschrieben, wie man Computerspiele im Unterricht einsetzt und tut das auch erfolgreich. Und das andere ist, ich würde gerne Christoph noch dazu holen, der etwas zur Technik als Evolutionsfrage sagen möchte. Christoph, wie meinst du das und wie passt das zum Thema?
Na ja, also die Frage ist eigentlich die Folgende. Es gibt ja sozusagen immer so ein bisschen zwei Gruppen. Das eine sind halt die Leute, die sich für ein bestimmtes Thema interessieren.
Das fälle ich mich jetzt mal mit zu und ihr ja sicherlich auch.
Die andere Frage ist aber, was macht sozusagen der Mainstream? Und der Mainstream benutzt ja eine Technologie, sei es jetzt meinetwegen das Internet, sei es Facebook oder sei es früher mal irgendwie das Rad, wenn es das einfachste ist, was er machen kann. So, sprich, wenn jetzt keine Ahnung, ein 12-jähriges Schulkind mit seinen Freunden kommunizieren will, hat es das früher per Telefon gemacht, jetzt ist es aber sowieso ständig am Rechner. Das heißt, da kann es auch mal eben schnell eine Nachricht auf Facebook oder Studiefortzeit beziehungsweise Schülerfortzeit in dem Fall posten. Genau das Gleiche ist, wenn Politiker sich jetzt mit dem iPad in den Bundestag stellen, früher mussten sie halt irgendwie riesig viel Dokumente ausdrucken. Jetzt können sie einfach ihren Handrechner mitnehmen und sich vorne hinstellen und das Skript irgendwie da aus ihrem Rechner rausziehen und noch schnell interaktiv sich Sachen, Informationen aus dem Netz ziehen zum Beispiel.
Ist das möglich, aber ist das Realität?
Na ja, also in der letzten Bundestagsdebatte, die ich gesehen hab, saßen drei Politiker irgendwie mit iPads vorne drin.
Also von daher, ja schon.
Vor allem deshalb jetzt iPads, weil Laptops immer noch nicht erlaubt sind.
Ja, weil das Ding darf keine Tastatur haben, die klappert, darf nicht zum Klappen sein und keine Lüfter haben. Und es gibt nicht viele Geräte, also größere Geräte, die diese Anforderung erfüllen. Aber ja, da tut sich auch ein bisschen. Allerdings in den Parlamenten, so wie ich gehört habe, funktioniert das WLAN trotzdem nicht so gut. Ich glaube, im Bundestag ist es so, dass Mustern vorher angefordert und eingeschaltet werden.
Ja, so funktioniert das nicht ganz so einfach. Eigentlich ist ja der Punkt, wann benutzt Autonormalverbraucher irgendeine Technik? Also meiner Meinung nach, wenn meine Oma sich jetzt vor drei Monaten entschieden hat, E-Mails zu benutzen, obwohl sie mir fünf Jahre vorher oder fünf Jahre lang irgendwie erzählt hat, es ist alles Raumschiff Enterprise, braucht sie nicht, dann tut sie das, weil sie jetzt eine Freundin hat, die in einem relativ weit entfernten Land wohnt, mit der sie jetzt relativ einfach kommunizieren kann, ohne dass sie teure Telefonkosten oder so auf sich nehmen muss. Dann benutzt sie halt einfach einen E-Mail-Client, weil es ist halt das Einfachste in dem Moment.
Und du meinst, das wird sozusagen auch, also nur das wird sich durchsetzen? Das heißt, es geht gar nicht so sehr um die Vermittlung von Kulturkompetenzen oder Technikultur, sondern es wird einfach das passieren, das beste Gerät oder der beste Service, der gebaut wurde?
Ja, schon. Also ich glaube, dass vielleicht in fünf Jahren benutzen dann alle sowas wie, meines Weges, Twitter oder so. Weil es dann wieder der einfachste Weg ist, Nachrichten zu verbreiten. Gut, wir haben dann in fünf Jahren vielleicht wieder was ganz, ganz anderes. Aber so der Mainstream wächst da, glaube ich, ja, wächst da rein. Es dauert halt eine Zeit, bis solche Entwicklungen ja sozusagen in der Kultur im Leben ankommen. Und die Leute, die sozusagen die Pionierarbeit leisten, sind dann schon wieder an einer anderen Baustelle. Der Schmerz muss einfach groß genug werden, es nicht zu benutzen.
Richtig, genau.
Ja, aber der Punkt beim Internet oder überhaupt bei der Technologie momentan ist ja auch, dass die Entwicklung so rasant vorangeht. Werd vor ein paar Jahren noch an Twitter, an Facebook oder ähnliches im Mainstream gedacht, dass sich das alles immer schneller entwickelt und wir ein Problem haben werden, dahinterher zu kommen.
Na das war ja schon immer so. Also es war immer schon, war alles was Neues, war alles schlimm. Und viel zu schnell. Und früher war es sozusagen sowieso langsamer. Also ich erinnere mich in diesen Fällen immer gerne an die Romane, vor denen früher gewarnt wurde, weil die verursachen Haltungsschäden, machen Jugendliche einsam und aggressiv und führen möglicherweise dazu, dass sie andere Leute umbringen.
Es ist einfach alles Teufelszeug. Ich meine, das ist jetzt wirklich nichts Neues, da wiederholt sich die Geschichte. Ich denke, wir drehen uns jetzt auch so in der Diskussion so ein bisschen im Kreis. Mich würde ja mal ein bisschen interessieren.
Wir haben gleich sozusagen, ich wollte gerade das aufgreifen und sagen, an diesem Punkt kommen wir wahrscheinlich nicht mehr weiter, drehen uns selber, also genau wie die Geschichte im Kreis, wir deshalb Marcel, Sven und Christoph vielen Dank sagen und noch einen schönen Abend wünschen. Und wir haben jetzt das andere Extrem, nämlich dabei, jemand der sagt, es geht auch noch ganz ohne Internet. Da bin ich sehr gespannt, wie das wird.
Wir müssen auch noch mal kurz eine kleine Denkpause haben. Nein, um das mal aufzugreifen, was jetzt hier so auch rauskommt. Ein immer wiederkehrender Konflikt aus den letzten 15 Jahren, den wir immer wieder gesehen haben, genau diese Diskussion, wie es sich jetzt auch entfaltet hat, das Neue gegen das Alte und was du schon gesagt hast, wo kommt sie denn so her, diese Medienkompetenz? Ich denke, das war ja auch eigentlich ein Dauerthema von Chaosradio, bzw. auch eigentlich das Thema von Chaosradio ist ja diese Vermittlung für, also Offenheit überhaupt erstmal für diese Themen zu haben, bzw. auch ganz konkret eben umgehen mit diesen Technologien, gefördert dadurch, dass man eben auch erstmal so eine respektlose Haltung gegenüber der Technik hat, was glaube ich gerade beim CCC auch immer sehr deutlich zutage kommt und auch so Grundsatzverständnis ist.
Ist das eigentlich empfehlenswert, die Umgebung der Technik? Also sollte sich das jeder aneignen? Respektlos?
Es ist mir auch aufgefallen, es ist auch zum Teil eine ganz schön typisch deutsche Diskussion, auch wieder dieser Unterschied, so die Amerikaner, neue Technik. Boah, zeig mal, was kann ich damit machen? Den Deutschen, oh, eine neue Technik. Ist das auch sicher? Was kann da passieren?
Welche Gefahren drohen?
Ja, das ist sicher auch so ein Stück weit Mentalität. Ich will nicht sagen, dass das eine und das andere jetzt besser ist. Also wenn man sich dann anguckt, wohin die Amerikaner sich zum Teil vergaloppiert haben, sind das so ein bisschen fast die zwei Extreme einer Medaille. Man wird sich da vielleicht ein bisschen mehr sowas in der Mitte wünschen. Den Amerikanern eher einen etwas vorsichtigeren Umgang mit Technik und Technikkultur. Und bei uns vielleicht manchmal ein bisschen weniger Technikangst. Aber es zeigt sich auch immer ganz gut, wenn das halt, wenn man jetzt auch wieder 15 Jahre Chaosradio und 35 Jahre Chaos, welche Ausstrahlung diese Hacker-Kultur über den Atlantik gehabt hat. Und in beide Richtungen. Also das, denke ich, ist auch ein ganz interessantes Stück Geschichte.
Das stimmt. Also, ich weiß nicht, ob du das so mitbekommen hast, Markus, aber so diese Hacker-Spaces-Entwicklung. Als der Club gegründet wurde vor 30 Jahren, da war auch ein wichtiger oder es gab mehrere wichtige Auslöser, aber so vor allem diese frühe amerikanische Hacker-Kultur spielte natürlich eine ganz entscheidende Rolle. So Magazine wie Tab-Magazin etc. Damit ist Vauland auch immer unterm Arm rumgelaufen und das war auch so Inspiration und das war ja auch geprägt von diesem respektlosen Umgang. Die Phone-Freaks, die einfach gesagt haben, wir müssen kostenlose Telefonate führen, denn wenn wir für unsere Telefonate bezahlen, dann führen wir eine Tax an den Vietnamkrieg ab und das wollen wir nicht. Das war ja auch schon ganz klar Politik und Gesellschaft und Technologie, das war von Anfang an da in einem Topf zusammen. Und das hat eben auch die Gründung des Clubs mit inspiriert und über die Jahre haben wir dann in Amerika auch so diesen merkwürdigen gesellschaftlichen Verfall ja auch alle beobachten dürfen. Der auch so mit Paranoia nach außen, früher sozusagen die Definition des Einwanderungslandes, der Offenheit der ganzen Welt, sozusagen der Schmelztiegel von allem. Und jetzt sind sie irgendwie so vollkommen in ihrem, wir sind jetzt aber, ab jetzt sind wir ja aber Amerika und der Rest ist alles außen und böse und gefährlich und muss verhindert werden und darf nicht mehr einreisen. Jetzt wendet sich das Blatt auch genauso gegen die eigenen Leute. Mit diesen ganzen Kontrollen, die sie da jetzt haben im Flug, da zeigt sich das eben auch ganz plastisch. Und die Hackerkultur hat enorm gelitten. Also die Hacker waren dann lange Zeit doch das Böse und sozusagen die Definition des Cyberkriminellen und nicht. Also der Sprung zum Terroristen war da auch sehr nah. Das ist glaube ich auch so ein Grund, warum das bei uns auch immer auf so giftigen Boden fällt, wenn wieder mal so eine neue Terrorwelle heraufbeschworen wird, weil das haben wir einfach schon viel zu häufig gesehen. Und jetzt gibt es diese lustige Gegenentwicklung, dass in diesem doch sehr liberalen Deutschland der letzten 20, 30 Jahre eben der Club und drum herum ja auch eine Hacker Szene, die jetzt auch nicht nur unter dem Namen CCC zu führen ist, sich entwickelt hat. Und das vor vier Jahren ging das so eine Rückbewegung los in die USA, inspiriert wiederum durch die deutsche Szene. Und jetzt öffnen da überall diese Hacker Spaces.
Du musst mal kurz erklären, ob ich was ist.
Was ein Hacker Spaces ist. Ein Hacker Spaces ist ein Ort, an dem sich Leute treffen, die eben hacken wollen, in unserem Sinne, also die einfach Interesse haben, Technologie zu erforschen, Hands-on Sachen zu bauen, Elektronik zu bauen, auch Software zu machen, was auch immer, Dinge zu basteln, zu bauen, zu schaffen. Oder eben auch, wie das beim Club ja auch immer eine große Rolle spielt, auch so einen gewissenen, offenen Geist zu leben. Sich einfach mit Leuten zu treffen, die einfach offen sind für Dinge, für Neues, neophil sind. Das sind diese Orte. Die finden sich dann an solchen Orten zusammen, kaufen sich gemeinsam Hardware, wo man dann bauen kann und wo man sich gegenseitig Dinge beibringen kann. Es gab eine extreme Explosion dieser Hacker Spaces vor vier Jahren, nachdem so eine kleine Gruppe bei uns beim Camp aufgelaufen war und total breit war und dachte, das brauchen wir jetzt irgendwie auch. Warum gibt es das nicht in den USA? Und jetzt gibt es das überall. Und das wird darum so cool, dass man sich da schon wieder eine Menge zurückholen kann. So, aber jetzt hatten wir ja auch noch einen Anrufer.
Genau, jetzt kommen wir zu Daniel, für den wir auch glaube ich dann die Hacker Spaces brauchen, weil der meint, es geht auch noch ganz ohne Internet. Hallo Daniel.
Ich habe angerufen, weil mir das irgendwie aufgestoßen ist. Oder nicht aufgestoßen, aber ich habe ein bisschen, ist mir ein bisschen quergekommen von dem, was der Anrufer davor sagte. Und zwar, ich mag Generalitäten nicht. Und der meint, man muss jetzt der älteren Generation das beibringen und geht ja gar nicht mehr ohne. Und ich muss sagen, wenn ich mir zum Beispiel meine Großeltern angucke, also ich meine, meine Oma hat jetzt auch einen Computer bekommen von meinem Onkel. Und ich habe ihr auch rudimentär Schreiben beigebracht, weil sie da halt ihre Geschichten aufschreibt, die sie erlebt hat früher, weil sie die gerne vermachen will so. Aber an sich, die hat es halt früher mit der Schreibmaschine geschrieben. Und das Ding ist, also all diese Technik, die ich auch nutze, sehr viel noch und nöcher, ist ja an sich ist es alles Luxus. Also es geht auch ohne. Und ich meine, es gibt ja noch ganz, ganz viele Orte auf dieser Welt, wo es auch noch ohne geht. Und ich meine, es ist ja jetzt nicht so wie zum Beispiel Medizintechnologie oder so, die jetzt wirklich irgendwie das Leben verlängert oder Leben rettet. Sondern es ist einfach, man hat und das macht das Leben leichter und vielleicht auch ein bisschen komplizierter, weil man halt einfach Verantwortung abgibt oder Arbeit abgibt an andere, die dann von anderen gemacht werden, wo dann halt die Verantwortung bei anderen, bei Maschinen oder bei anderen Menschen oder anderen Diensten halt liegt.
Aber du bist online selbst, ja? Also du nutzt das Internet, ok. Also Briggs, jetzt dich, der das Internet benutzt und deine Großmutter, die jetzt das Internet benutzt, sind vielleicht keine so guten Beispiele dafür, dass das...
Nee, nee, meine Großmutter benutzt das Internet nicht. Sie hat bloß einen Computer, an dem sie lediglich Word benutzt. Aber den benutze ich auch sehr selten, weil sie den nicht so richtig auskriegt und ankriegt. Also es ist immer sehr kompliziert.
Das ist ja auch völlig in Ordnung. Ich meine, das ist halt die Kulturtechnik, die sie erlernt hat. Textverarbeitung, das konnten auch viele Leute nicht. Das können auch viele Leute heute nicht. Und ich finde das auch völlig in Ordnung. Ich meine, man muss ja gar nicht alles können. Und es ist auch, glaube ich, so die Zahl der Kulturtechniken, die man dann wirklich beherrscht, die ist auch endlich. Wenn man sich mal anguckt, was an Kulturtechniken auch, sagen wir mal, jetzt dem Aussterben, vom Aussterben bedroht ist, wenn man sich zum Beispiel mal anschaut, wie die Leute heutzutage schreiben, und ich meine nicht tippen, sondern schreiben, mit einem Stift auf einem Black-Papier.
Das Beispiel passt da natürlich sehr schön mit der Großmutter, die jetzt sogar auch zum Computer kann.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie noch in der Lage ist, ihre Handschrift zu verlernen. Vielleicht mag ihr der Computer da eine Hilfe sein, wenn das Schreiben jetzt medizinisch bedingt nicht mehr so geht. Aber ich merke halt auch, dass die Leute heutzutage nicht mehr so sehr viel von Hand schreiben. Und wenn man sich die Klaue von manchen Leuten anschaut, da läuft es mir kalt über den Rücken.
Du kriegst es auch nicht so leicht per E-Mail verschickt, dein handgeschriebenen Zettel.
Die Frage ist zu sagen, muss man das noch können? Also es ist ein großer Verlust. Also man könnte auch sagen, na ja, kann keiner mehr schreiben, ist aber auch egal.
Und kann sein, dass das so ist, ja, durchaus.
Und noch eine andere, also es geht ja nicht um die Frage, jetzt muss oder muss man nicht, also was ist jetzt unnötig so zum Überleben? Aber das wäre vielleicht noch eine Frage. So brauchen wir das Internet im Moment zum Überleben. Sieht zunehmend danach aus, dass das ernste Probleme verursachen würde, wenn es das jetzt nicht gäbe. Aber die Frage ist, will man das, will man ohne auskommen?
Also ich muss sagen, so weit wie unsere Gesellschaft ist, meiner Meinung nach, würde es wirklich ernste Probleme geben, wenn das Internet jetzt nicht mehr funktionieren würde, weil wirklich schon sehr viel darauf basiert. Ich will bloß sagen, dass man sich selbst entscheiden kann. Also die Gesellschaft als Ganzes würde meiner Meinung nach durchaus ernste Probleme kriegen. Aber Einzelne können sich durchaus wie auch einzelne Leute in Kommunen leben können oder einzelne Leute halt nicht Auto fahren können. Das sind jetzt mehr die Leute, die nicht Auto fahren. Aber wie einzelne Leute einzelne Sachen nicht machen, können sie auch sagen, ich will jetzt hier kein Internet haben.
Das ist ja unbenommen. Aber das sind ja dann die Einsiedler, die Außenseiter. Als Kulturtechnik, als Allgemein ist es schon nötig, oder nicht?
Also ich, nee, Außenseiter, ich weiß nicht. Ich will das nicht so für Allgemein. Ich habe auch meine Eigenheiten oder zum Beispiel habe ich auch kein Handy. Mag ich nicht. Ich bin noch ohne aufgewachsen und das hat noch funktioniert. Es funktioniert immer noch so. Ist auch eine Kostenfrage bei mir. Aber ich weiß nicht, ich fühle mich da nicht als Außenseiter und ich kann trotzdem mit meinen Freunden Probleme mitreden.
Würdest du denn lieber früher leben in einer Zeit, wo es das noch nicht gab und wo du nicht darauf verzichten musstest? Also stört dich irgendwas so an der modernen Technik?
Ob mich jetzt so was an der modernen Technik stört, ist ein bisschen schon die Unterkontrollierbarkeit, aber das geht jetzt glaube ich ein bisschen zu weit. Ich würde nicht früher leben, weil ich muss sagen, so sehr ich sage, auf vieles der Technik kann man verzichten. Gerade die medizinische Entwicklung ist das, was wirklich gut ist, auch wenn die Pharmaindustrie da sehr viel forscht, aber das ist das, was ich nicht zurückdrehen würde.
Ich möchte aber dann doch noch kurz nachfragen, auch wenn wir dann gleich wieder in Fritz Info haben, mit der Unkontrollierbarkeit der Technik. Was genau meinst du damit?
Na ja, also ich meine zum Beispiel, da ist die Tatsache, dass die Internetadressen, ich weiß nicht genau den Fachbegriff dafür, aber die Internetadressenverwaltung ja alles in den USA sitzt. Und wir hier aus Europa aus relativ wenig da machen können zum Beispiel.
Ja das, nein das, also so einfach ist die Antwort nicht. Ich glaub die Angst können wir dir nehmen. Also das ist schon...
Ja, aber ich meine...
Es gibt hier und da, sagen wir mal, Machtkonzentrationen, die vielleicht noch mehr im USA-Bereich liegen, als einem das manchmal liebt wäre. Aber es ist mitnichten so, dass das Internet vollständig aus den USA herauskommandiert wird. Die Zeiten sind auch vorbei.
Ja, ja, das weiß ich. Das meinte ich auch nicht. Ich wollte bloß ungefähr... Ich meine, ich hab auch ganz viele Chaos Radio Podcasts erst in letzter Zeit gehört, weil ich es erst vor einem Monat entdeckt habe. Nichtsdestotrotz wollte ich quasi sagen, ihr werdet viel ruhiger schlafen im Chaos Computer Club, wenn die, also wenn das, die ganze Technik wirklich so beherrschbar wäre, oder?
Aber wärs dann auch wieder langweilig?
Wir wissen, dass die nicht in dem Maße beherrschbar ist.
Ich glaube auch, das wäre natürlich langweilig, weil die Unbeherrschbarkeit der Technik, ein anderes Ergebnis ist ja sozusagen nicht nur der Verlust der Beherrschbarkeit, sondern ist halt auch der Umgang mit Kreativität. Also du kannst sie dann zu neuen Ufern treiben. Wenn sie komplett beherrscht und kontrollierbar wäre, dann ginge das ja nicht mehr.
Ja, das weiß ich, aber die Frage ist halt immer...
Also ich verstehe deinen Punkt. Und da ist ja auch, sagen wir mal, so eine Grundskepsis, die da mitschwenkt, die ich gut verstehen kann. Auf der anderen Seite denke ich, was du ein bisschen außer Acht lässt, und das zeigt sich an deinem Medizinbeispiel schon ganz gut so, es gibt schon einige Auswirkungen, die würdest du missen. Der Punkt ist, die gesamte Entwicklung der menschlichen Gesellschaft auf diesem Planeten in den letzten 20 Jahren, vor allem der letzten 10 Jahre, wäre so ohne das Internet nicht im Ansatz so gelaufen. Und der wissenschaftliche Gesamtgewinn geht natürlich auch weit über Medizin hinaus. Das ist wohl etwas, wo man den persönlichen Nutzen am besten verstehen kann, aber so allein, dass diese Welt überhaupt erst mal begreift, was sie eigentlich ist, unsere Position im Universum und sozusagen unser Verhältnis und die Verletzlichkeit dieses Planeten ist, das ist ja mitnichten angekommen, da braucht man nur gleich wieder auf die Nachrichten warten, dann kommt da wahrscheinlich gleich wieder so, na ja, Atomkraftwerke laufen jetzt nochmal 10 Jahre und so weiter. Da sind so viele Leute, die überhaupt nicht auch nur eine Spur Verständnis davon haben, was ja eigentlich ist, da ist noch viel nachzuholen. Ohne Internet wird uns das nicht gelingen, dieses Wissen aufzubauen und zu verbreiten und die Leute von ihrem Aberglauben zu befreien. Der Meinung ist, die Welt wäre 2000 Jahre alt und irgendwann mal ausgenießt worden.
Und es läuft natürlich auch schon längst der Kampf ums Internet. Also der wird auf ganz vielen Ebenen ausgefochten. Der politische Kampf um die Kontrolle der Technik, der Infrastruktur, der Umsätze, der Informationsflüsse. Also das ist schon auch dann zu etwas geworden, wo das Leben tatsächlich stattfindet.
Also Daniel, ich würde sagen, wir halten fest, du darfst gerne ohne Internet, wenn du unbedingt willst. Wir wollen es aber trotzdem behalten und sind der Ansicht, dass es eine gute Idee ist.
Ich meine, wenn man mich vor die Wahl stellen würde, ob ich es zurückdrehen möchte oder nicht, wenn ich könnte, würde ich es nicht machen. Die Frage war ja, ob ich auch ohne Internet leben würde.
Boah, also wegen, weil das Internet weg ist, würde glaube ich keiner Selbstmord begehen hier, aber man hätte, äh, nee, aber Mord.
Selbstmord nicht, aber Mord. Also das Internet würde schon deshalb nicht verschwinden, weil ich sonst stinkteufels wild wär.
Kann ich noch mal kurz dranbleiben und dann in der Dings was sagen?
In der Dings?
In der Info-Sendung.
Das ist schwierig, weil das alles aus dem selben Studio läuft. Aber wir gucken mal, was wir machen können. Ich sag auf jeden Fall trotzdem jetzt schon mal Tschüss und kündige an, dass wir ein Fritz Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr jetzt machen. Und danach geht's noch eine halbe Stunde weiter mit dem Chaosradio. Heute Chaosradio, eine halbe Stunde geht das 15-jährige Jubiläum. Und zu Gast sind Pavel Meier und Tim Prittler. Hallo und guten Abend nochmal. Ich habe gerade einen Pfaden verloren. Kannst du dir mal kurz erklären, worüber wir den letzten 1, 5 Stunden geredet haben?
Mir viel gerade noch. Das erklärt Tim gleich immer mehr. Da wir die Möglichkeit haben, hier die Nachrichten zu kommentieren, wie es sonst nur im Internet geht. Das zeitliche Zusammenfallen natürlich mit den Haushaltsverhandlungen von dem ganzen Terrorwahn, das ist natürlich jetzt ganz unglücklich, dass das passiert. Da muss man ja jetzt wieder viel Geld ausgeben. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass es auch Zufall ist. Also ich habe da nicht wirklich irgendwelche Einblicke, aber praktisch ist es natürlich schon, dass das Ganze gerade zusammenfällt.
Ja, ich fand es auch bemerkenswert, dass da gleich so eine Innenministerkonferenz zwei Tage danach stattfand, nachdem so die ersten Warnungen aufkamen. Solche Zufälle, ja.
Und auch schön, keine Gefahr, bitte weitergehen. Es ist eigentlich keine Gefahr. Gerade die Menschen müssen zusammenhalten, ist auch ein schöner Appell, jetzt die Berliner zusammenzuhalten.
Total. Also ich würde in dem Zusammenhang nochmal auf wirhabenkeineangst.de verweisen. Eine schöne Initiative von Mario Sixtus, wo sich Leute zusammenfinden, die irgendwie schnallen, was abgeht. Naja, aber eigentlich werden wir gar nicht über Terror reden.
Aber das führt mich gerade zu einem Thema, die schnallen, was abgeht. Weil, was ich ja finde, ist, manchmal hat mir der Eindruck, das Internet und die ganze Verbreitung von Informationen hat nicht dazu geführt, dass sich jetzt jeder eine eigene Meinung bildet, sondern dass es jetzt noch mehr Leute gibt, die glauben, sie wüssten, was abgeht. Noch mehr als? Früher war es so, es gab halt die klassischen Medien, und darüber die Politiker quasi, in der Informationsherarchie, und die wussten, was abgeht. Und jetzt gibt es sozusagen, jeder informiert sich im Netz, er hat drei verschiedenen Quellen, und er weiß dann auch, was abgeht.
Ich meine, mit diesem früher, das ist ja alles relativ. Kommt drauf an, was für ein früher du jetzt meinst. Ich könnte ja jetzt auch mal ganz böse sein, und früher, als das Radio erfunden wurde, da hingen sie irgendwie alle vor ihrem Volksempfänger, und da wurde da irgendwie reingegöbbelt, mit, ja, vorwärts immer, rückwärts nimmer, und der Feind steht vor der Tür, und wir müssen jetzt alle, unsere Söhne und Töchter, irgendwie in den Krieg schmeißen. Und es gab einfach keine Möglichkeit, irgendwie irgendeine Gegenkommunikation aufzumachen.
Ja genau, aber das war der streichgenaue Punkt, den ich machen wollte. Nämlich, es gab früher sozusagen diese eine Öffentlichkeitsmeinung, die wurde sozusagen eingetrichtert, aufgrund dessen, dass es halt wenige Quellen gab. Heute gibt es mehr Quellen. Das führt aber nicht dazu, dass es zu einer großen Konsenswahrheit kommt, die alle miteinander reden können. Sondern es kommt nur dazu, dass viel mehr Leute glauben, sie sind jetzt informiert und haben die eine Wahrheit rausgefunden.
Es gibt halt jetzt auch für die alternativen Wahrheiten, gibt es auch Kommunikationsforen, die es so vorher nicht gab. Aber das gilt natürlich auch noch für die unterdrückende Macht, meine Meinung, die es eben auch schon vorher gab. Und alle kämpfen da mit denselben Bandagen. Das ist klar, so ist das nun mal. Also nur, weil das Internet da ist, ist noch nicht alles besser geworden. Aber ich denke, ohne das Internet gibt es wenig Potenzial, dass es sich verbessern kann. Und das ist halt einfach jetzt ein gesellschaftlicher Konflikt, der ausgetragen werden muss.
Ja, also die Spielregeln haben sich sicherlich ein Stück weit verändert, was so Informationskontrolle angeht. Wobei es gab halt früher eben eine größere Vielfalt an Zeitungen. Aber tatsächlich die Bandbreite hat zugenommen, die Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten haben zugenommen und die Möglichkeiten, das Ganze zu kontrollieren und zu kanalisieren, haben abgenommen. Aber sie sind halt nicht komplett weg. Es gibt auch im Internet natürlich die großen Meinungs-Schleudern.
Deswegen sind wir ja wieder beim Thema. Deswegen denke ich, ist es sehr wichtig, zu betonen, Technikkultur, das ist etwas, was es schon immer gab. Das ist jetzt nichts Neues, würde ich sagen. Aber es gibt schon diese spezifische, elektronische, netzartige Technikkultur der letzten 20 Jahre, die sich eben mit dem Computer gebildet hat. Die einfach noch mal eine andere, also eine Computertechnikkultur, könnte man auch sagen, die sich jetzt herausgebildet hat, in der sich eben Kunst entwickelt, Meinungen entwickeln, im allgemeinen Sinne Kultur entwickelt. Auch der CCC ist eine Ausprägung dieser Kultur. Es gibt tausende andere Ausprägungen dieser Kultur. Die Apple-Kultur. Aber es geht letztendlich darum, das ist immer so ein ewiger Kreislauf, neue Kulturtechniken zu erwerben. Und dieses allgemeine Umgehen mit dem Netz und diskutieren, was ich ja vorhin schon gesagt habe, das ist womit das Schwerste überhaupt, weil das so eine totale Metakulturtechnik ist. Klar, das ist sozusagen das hohe Ziel, da muss man in kleinen Schritten hinkommen. Aber dazu gehört, dass man sich dem ganzen überhaupt erst mal positiv entgegenstellt und sagt, ja, ich bin auch offen, ich bin neophil, ich will das jetzt wissen und ich will das verstehen und ich will es selber verstehen und ich will es mir selber erarbeiten und ich will selber alles erst mal hinterfragen und ich möchte bitte nicht einfach nur akzeptieren, was mir vorgesetzt wird, weder von meinen Eltern, noch von meinem Lehrer, noch vom Fernseher. Alles Zweifelhafte muss angezweifelt werden. So ein Aufkleber beim Chaos Computer Club Berlin finde ich ganz großartig, der klebt da irgendwie an der Tür und der sagt schon mal eine Menge aus.
Ja, es ist auch tatsächlich, dass im Prinzip alte Konzepte der Aufklärung wieder in Mode kommen mit dem Internet, nämlich für sich selbst zu denken, beziehungsweise, nein, dem Internet in der Hacker-Kultur. Die Hacker-Kultur ist halt auch eigentlich eine Kultur in der Tradition der Aufklärung, weil man dort ja auch versucht, nicht nur Dinge zu machen, sondern dann auch allen anderen mitzuteilen, dass man sie gemacht hat und wie man sie gemacht hat und einfach das Wissen zu mehren und zu verbreiten. Und andere in die Lage zu versetzen, das auch zu tun.
Na ja, es gibt auch die Ansicht von auch, dass gerade Hacker zu so einer Art Elitenabschottung tendieren. Also das schon gerne mitteilen, aber nur den Leuten, die es auch verdient haben, diese Informationen zu erwerben.
Ja, es ist vielleicht aber auch nicht ganz unwichtig, dass da auch eine gewisse soziale Kontrolle auf jeden Fall stattfindet, wobei sie letztendlich nicht wirklich stattfindet.
Ja, machen wir uns nichts vor. Wir sind ja auch ein ganz schön arrogantes Pack manchmal. Da gab es auch genug Chaosradiosendungen, die will man sich eigentlich nicht nochmal anhören. Weil manchmal hat man natürlich auch durch dieses viele Wissen, kommt man schnell in so eine Position der Überheblichkeit, die ist nicht unbedingt immer hilfreich.
Aber meistens.
Aber halt genau beim Kern des Problems angelangt.
Finde ich selbst immer. Für die große Sache müssen wir mal sehen.
Ja, ist schwierig. Ich meine, ich bin so jemand, der dem Wort Elite nicht so viel Negatives abgewinnen kann. Das ist schon so eine gewisse Auslese, das hat natürlich auch jede, das bringt so jede Gruppe auch mit sich. Warum? Wie findet man denn seine Peer Group? Man wählt sich halt die Leute, die dazugehören, wählt man aus. Und es gibt halt Leute, die passen da rein. Und es gibt Leute, die passen da nicht rein. Und man wählt sich eben die Gruppe so, dass man eine Atmosphäre, eine Kultur der Kommunikation erreicht, wie sie einem eben passt. Es gibt Gruppen, die eben eine Kultur der Kommunikation haben wollen, die so ein bisschen minder qualitativ ist. Ja, was weiß ich, so bei Rechtsextremen oder so. Da geht das halt nicht so intelligent zur Sache. Aber in der Hacker-Kultur habe ich halt eine Menge außerordentlich intelligenter Menschen kennengelernt. Die waren nicht unbedingt immer in der Lage, ihre Intelligenz auch in Kommunikation umzusetzen. Die Nerds, die halt wirklich so in so einem Thema drin sind, sind nicht unbedingt immer in der Lage, das zu erklären. Aber das ist eben auch etwas, was man erlernen muss. Und insofern ist, glaube ich, auch Chaosradio für uns so ein bisschen Therapie geworden. Ja, ganz ehrlich. Um einfach das dann auch hinzubekommen, dass man dieses ganze Wissen und diese ganze Verantwortung, die man dann auch damit immer verbindet, das ist ja auch so ein starkes Moment im Club, dass man das auch kanalisiert bekommt. Das gelingt natürlich nicht immer, aber probieren muss man es.
Eine Gegenkultur, um das nochmal, also eine Gegenkultur zur Hacker-Kultur ist so die Marketing-Kultur. Die Marketing-Droiden sind sicherlich, das sind so die Gebrauchtwagenhändler unter den Informationsmaklern. Die versuchen einem mit jedem Trick, einem nicht tatsächlich die Wahrheit aufzuschätzen, sondern zu versuchen, einen zu manipulieren. Ich glaube, dass das ein wichtiges kulturelles Mittel jetzt auch ist, sich zu immunisieren gegen solche Informationsmanipulatoren. Das war glaube ich auch immer wieder so ein wichtiges Anliegen. Deswegen gegen Produkte, also Produkte immer wieder zu enttarnen oder bestimmte Dinge, die die Politik verspricht, die sie nicht halten kann, zu enttarnen, zu entblößen. Das denke ich ist auch ein wichtiger Moment.
Ich würde jetzt gerne noch den Jan reinnehmen. Jan ist 20, kommt aus Duisburg. Und ich weiß gar nicht, ist dir das alles zu komplex oder noch nicht komplex genug mit der Technik?
Ja, also wie soll ich sagen?
Na ja, erstmal, erstmal fang ich glaube ich, ich hab mir schon eine ganze Menge überlegt, was ich noch sagen wollte. Aber ich fang jetzt vielleicht mal direkt an bei dem Anrufer von vorhin. Und zwar hat er gesagt, es geht auch ohne. Und ja, ich glaube es muss manchmal auch ohne Internet gehen. Und zwar ist es so, Internet hat ja eine Menge so Möglichkeiten und Computer und Technik überhaupt. Aber wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel so in den Tante Emma Schuhladen komme, so von nebenan, was mir neulich passiert ist und die mir sagen, sie können mir heute so überhaupt keine Schuhe mehr verkaufen, weil bei denen ein Virus im System ist und die haben da vielleicht so, ich sag mal 100 Paar Schuhe stehen. Und sie können mir halt keinen Schuh verkaufen, weil da halt Virus im System. Dann frag ich mich, wofür muss die Technik da so unbedingt eingesetzt werden? Ich finde es auf jeden Fall gut, dass wir so Leute haben, wie jetzt im CCC, die sich dann halt mit der Technik beschäftigen. Aber die Frage ist dann halt, muss die Technik, nur weil sie da ist, auch überall eingesetzt werden? Und ich glaube, das muss halt nicht. Und ich glaube, da muss man auch so ein bestimmtes Mittelmaß finden.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich meine, das haben wir ja, brauchen wir nur das Thema Wahlcomputer aufzugreifen, was ja auch gerne so als naja, wir müssen ja modern sein. Wir brauchen jetzt Computer und wählen ohne Computer geht ja gar nicht. Da hat der Club ja auch ganz klar positionbezogen und gesagt, das geht gar nicht.
Ja, und da ist so die Geschichte mit der Komplexität. Also ich glaube auch so von wegen so Technikkultur und Kulturtechnik. Ich meine, das gab es alles auch irgendwie schon mal, auch so mit der Zurverfügungstellung von Informationen. Ich meine, ich glaube nicht, dass das beim Buchdruck damals jetzt wesentlich anders war. Also da war es früher auch, ok, Informationen wurden jetzt mündlich weitergegeben und irgendwann ist mal so eine kleine Elite darauf gekommen und hat gesagt, ok, wir fangen jetzt an, wir bringen das auf Papier und das war am Anfang auch alles ganz teuer und so eine Druckmaschine und Papier konnte sich auch nicht jeder leisten. Und es wurde dann auch komplexer, man braucht irgendwie was weiß ich, eine Bibliothek, wo man das alles lagern konnte. Und jetzt hat man halt so Rechnerinfrastruktur, nur entwickelt sich das halt eben immer weiter und wird immer komplexer. Und die Frage ist halt, in wie weit das Ganze dann noch beherrschbar ist.
Ja, das ist immer die Frage, obwohl ich glaube, dass eher die Entwicklung halt genau in diese Richtung geht, nämlich in diese Beherrschbarkeit. Also das ist glaube ich der große Trend, den wir derzeit erleben.
Ja, oder unsere Technik erwacht dann endgültig zum Leben ist vielleicht schon passiert und die Kontrolle entgleitet uns komplett, beziehungsweise da verselbstständigt sich so ein Konglomerat aus natürlichen und künstlichen Intelligenzen und Informationsverarbeitung und Netzwerken. Aber vielleicht war das sowieso auch schon immer so und vielleicht ist das eh nur eine Illusion mit der ganzen Kontrolle über den Gang der Dinge.
Also was ich jetzt zum Beispiel auch noch so in so einem anderen Punkt öfter mal so ein bisschen jetzt plötzlich negativ betrachtet, also ich meine ich bin quasi damit aufgewachsen. Ich war glaube ich schon so in der Grundschule, habe ich so meinen ersten Computer gehabt und Internet war ich auch relativ früh dabei und was mir jetzt halt aufgefallen ist, so in den letzten Jahren ist halt doch relativ oberflächlich auch geworden, so durch die Informationsgewinnung, so wurde ja jetzt heute Abend auch schon drüber gesprochen.
Was ist oberflächlich geworden?
Ja die Hart und Weise, wie man jetzt Informationen verarbeitet und gewinnt. Twitter reduziert sich plötzlich auf so und so viel Zeichen.
Warte mal, Mann oder Du? Allgemeinerst du das jetzt oder bei dir?
So etwas allgemeiner würde ich das schon sagen. Viele schreiben jetzt nur noch irgendwelche Statusnachrichten und keine Briefe mehr oder so. Einige Zeitungen beziehen jetzt irgendwie so just in time irgendwelche Informationen aus dem Netz komplett ungesichert. Und das ist jetzt so eine gewisse Oberflächlichkeit. Und auch so beim Arbeiten.
Ich merke das jetzt an der Uni immer wieder.
Geht man halt ins Netz, sucht sich die erstbeste Quelle und übernimmt das dann einfach, hinterfragt nicht viel. Und die Frage ist jetzt so, ist Kompetenz überhaupt noch jetzt zukünftig was Neues zu schaffen oder einfach nur zu wissen, wo man das Richtige herbekommt?
Also was mir dazu einfällt, ist der Satz Imminent Death of the Net Predicted. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das schon mal gehört hast, aber das ist irgendwie 30 Jahre alt und das ist sozusagen die Erkenntnis, die Leute, die damals Usenet, das war sozusagen noch vor dem Internet da war, was dann später Newsgroups hieß. Die Diskussionskultur dort wurde allgemein als sich in einem Zustand der Verrohung und Verdummung angesehen und es wurde der unmittelbare Tod des Netzes vorausgesagt. Das hat sich sozusagen zu so einem Mem entwickelt und das höre ich bei dir jetzt auch so ein bisschen raus. Ich glaube, dass man das einfach so nicht sehen braucht, weil man kann viel reden, ohne was zu sagen. Fasse dich kurz kann auch eine Qualität sein. Deswegen, dass Twitter sich auf 140 Zeichen beschränkt, das sagt gar nichts aus. Das kann gut sein, das kann schlecht sein. Im Wesentlichen ist es erstmal vollkommen irrelevant. Also ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt irgendeine qualitative Aussage ist. Es ist eine quantitative Aussage, aber es ist keine qualitative Aussage.
Ja, das behaupte ich auch eigentlich gar nicht. Ich sage halt nur, man müsste dann wirklich drauf achten und dass es eben nicht abgleitet, dass man eben auch da so eine Art Mittelmaß findet. Also es gibt halt Informationen, auch wenn man sie dann auf 140 Zeichen packen kann, die braucht man halt nicht. Und es gibt halt Informationen, die muss man auf mehr Zeichen packen. Das sollte man auch bitte tun. Und es gibt eben Informationen, die sind für dieses Medium geeignet. Und ja, man sollte sich dann doch auch darauf beschränken, dass man diese Informationen dann da angibt und nicht die Informationen, die nicht in das Medium passen, dann an das Medium anzupassen.
Ich meine, da muss man halt erstmal stolpern, bevor man weiß, wie man läuft.
Aber es werden auch nach wie vor noch Bücher geschrieben und gelesen. Ich glaube, so diese Panik, die Bücher sterben aus, die habe ich jetzt lange nicht mehr gehört. Das war, glaube ich, so im Zusammenhang mit Fernsehen. Da war, glaube ich, keiner liest mehr und Bücher sterben aus.
Naja, mit Detett gab es das schon auch nochmal. Da hat es schon mal ein kleines Revival. Aber das letzte Mal wahrscheinlich ist diese Angst untergegangen, als jemand bemerkt hat, dass man auf diesen E-Readern im prallen Sonnenlicht halt noch so geil lesen kann. Bücher wird es auch noch eine Weile geben. So meine Herren, 10 Minuten vor um ist es. Das heißt, das 15-jährige Jubiläum des Chaosradios nähert sich langsam mit dem Ende. Jan, dir würde ich sozusagen, als der, der uns hier als Erster verlassen muss, das erste Schluss-Pleiluier zuteilen. Was wünschst du dir für die nächsten 15 Jahre vielleicht?
Eigentlich, dass es so weitergeht. Ich finde die Diskussion immer sehr interessant. Eigentlich kann es so weitergehen. Und ich bin gespannt, was noch so alles kommt.
Na gut, das können wir machen. Vielen Dank und schöne Habt ihr noch. Bis denn, tschüss.
Das sagst du einfach so.
15 Jahre.
Mein Gott, sollen wir hier noch als Greise sitzen?
Dann bin ich sehr wütend. Es heißt ja Chaosradio. Vielleicht findet ihr auch innerhalb dieses seltsamen Gefügels, dass sich der Club nennt, eine...
Was?
Entkreisungsstadt.
Passiert schon. Entkreisungen. Das kann man dem Club glaube ich nicht wirklich vorwerfen, dass er so altern würde wie die Volksparteien oder so.
Ich finde, wir sind eigentlich noch ganz jung geblieben irgendwo.
Wir machen uns Gedanken drüber, wenn wir alle zum Club treffen, in Anzug erscheinen müssen. Und hier offizielle Farben schliebt. Gibt es eigentlich offizielle Farben vom TTC?
Man hat sich ja noch nicht mal auf ein Logo einigen können.
Okay, also das Chaosradio wird vielleicht nicht die nächsten 50 Jahre, aber ich sage mal, auf absehbare Zeit irgendwie so weitergehen.
Ja, also solange ihr noch diese UKW-Frequenz habt, kommen wir auch noch regelmäßig rum. Aber wenn sie euch die mal abdrehen, dann...
Ja, das mit dem UKW ist natürlich so eine Sache, ne?
Also Entschuldigung, der MP3, für wen haben wir den denn geholt? Also bitte. Er sagt gerade hier, wenn UKW weg, dann kein Chaosradio mehr.
Dann müssen wir nicht jedes Mal hier so weit nach Potsdam rausfahren.
Da wird auch keiner dieses teure Studio mehr heizen.
Eigentlich hättet ihr heute in den zwei Stunden auch die Möglichkeit gehabt, mal ordentlich abzumeckern über das Chaosradio. Das habt ihr irgendwie nicht so wahrgenommen. Vielleicht gibt es auch einfach nichts zu meckern, was ich wiederum nicht glauben kann, wenn man ab und zu mal die Kommentare auf Twitter oder im Chat liest. Aber es gibt auch noch die Seite zur Sendung, wo man das zum Beispiel im Blog machen kann, wo der Podcast in dieser wunderbaren Sendung auch demnächst erscheinen wird. Aber zurück zum Thema Kulturtechnik Technik Kultur. Wie sieht es bei euch aus, die nächsten 15 Jahre?
Ach, immer diese Zukunftsfragen.
Jetzt hab ich mich bis hierher zurückgehalten. Ich hab so noch drei Minuten.
Ich hätte jetzt nett sein müssen, ne?
Nee.
Ich find ja immer die Gegenwart viel interessanter als die Zukunft.
Was ist denn mit der Gegenwart? Hat sich für dich heute noch was geändert? An deiner Sicht auf die Gegenwart?
Heute im Sinne, im Rahmen dieser Sendung? Genau. Was ich gut finde, was ich immer wieder gerne höre, ist natürlich, dass, so wie gerade auch der erste Anruf war, also auch das, was wir hier versucht haben zu entwickeln, auch so verstanden wird, das finde ich toll. Das begeistert mich wirklich. Hätte ich nicht so erwartet, glaube ich, als wir damit angefangen hatten. Aber das lag auch daran, glaube ich, dass wir eigentlich gar keine Erwartungen hatten. Trotzdem finde ich das extrem stark. Und ich habe gemerkt, dass es sinnvoll ist, auch selber sich so einer Diskussion zu stellen. Und viele, die in dieser ganzen Diskussion drin sind und dieser Problematik so, oh ja, ich habe so ein bisschen geschneit, wie der Hase läuft, wie die Welt tickt, aber alle meine Freunde vergammeln auf Facebook und tauschen sich über Fernsehserien aus. Ich kenne diesen Frust, der ist schlimm. Und ich denke, dass man darüber auf jeden Fall nicht verzweifeln sollte und dass es ohnehin sehr viel sinnvoller ist, sich eben den Leuten zuzuwenden, die diese Bereitschaft zum Verständnis bereits entwickelt haben und dass man da mit den Leuten ansetzt, die eben auch schon erste Schritte zeigen, aus der Matrix aufzuwachen, wo hinten der Stecker schon so ein bisschen wackelt. Da muss man ansetzen. Und da muss man sich auch drauf konzentrieren. Das hat überhaupt keinen Sinn. Die ganze Zeit in so Oh Gott, das ist alles so furchtbar und so schlimm und alle sind so doof und Idiocracy und die Dummen werden siegen. Ich glaube das überhaupt nicht. Ich glaube, dass der generelle Trend eher für die Aufklärung spricht. Da braucht man sich nur die Menschheitsgeschichte anzuschauen. Ich meine, wir hatten auch mal ganz andere Zeiten auf diesem Planeten und das ist alles noch gar nicht so lange her. Die ganze Menschheit der Homo Sapiens, da sind gerade mal 40.000 Generationen. Die Wechsel werden von Generationen immer schneller, sodass man eben einfach aufbrechen sollte und offen kommuniziert und thematisiert. Und das bewirkt eben auch was.
Das Internet ist auf jeden Fall eine gute Ergänzung zum echten Leben und nicht so ein Ersatz für echtes Leben, wie das Fernsehen manchmal der Fall ist. Und ich hoffe, dass es nicht zu einem Ersatz wird in den nächsten 15 Jahren. Also es wird natürlich, gehe ich mal von aus, schneller werden, das Internet. Es wird mehr mobiles Internet geben. Wahrscheinlich werde ich noch mehr Rechner mit mir rumschleppen, als ich das jetzt tue in allen Größen. Oder in verschiedenen Formaten.
Was ihr dazu wissen müsst, ist, dass Pavel seit geraumer Zeit mit einem Smartphone, einem Tablet-Rechner und einem Notebook mit mir direkt gegenüber sitzt.
Ja und ein Ersatztelefon habe ich natürlich noch in der Tasche mit anderen Betriebssystemen.
Meine Hoffnung wäre ja, ich brauche demnächst nur noch ein Gerät.
Der Trend geht zum 5. Computer.
Ja, wird nicht passieren.
Okay, mit dieser Voraussicht beschließen wir die heutige Sendung. Vielen Dank, dass ihr vorbeigekommen seid und es einen kleinen Ausblick in Kultur, Technik und Technik Kultur gegeben hat. Nach diesem Chaosradio, dass ihr demnächst als Podcast auch euch einfach von der Seite ziehen könnt, gibt es den Night Flight mit Florian Heiler. Und der wird euch sozusagen, falls euch die Ohren jetzt ein bisschen zugequast sind, die wieder frei blasen mit ordentlich Punkmusik. Und vorher gibt es natürlich noch den traditionellen Abschlusssong von Trackey Birthday und DRAG an Espen Sheet Website. Herzlich willkommen zum Night Flight auf Fritz.
Freitagmorgen 0 Uhr.
Liebe Nerds und Nahelesen, weg vom Computer, rauf auf die Tanzfläche, mal mit den Mädchen sprechen.